[Music]
Disney Princesses service role models
for millions of children all over the
world these celebrated characters might
appear to be living on a cloud but truth
is they have some untold truths of their
own stay tuned to find out which Disney
families have held on to super dark
secrets for way too long first time at
the things don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
our Channel
are you ready to find out the truth
about these Disney families let's get
started
Snow White's gullible father if there's
one Disney princess who knows a thing or
two about fending for herself it's Snow
White this beautiful princess was chased
from her very own castle when she was
only 14 years old but the truth is her
turmoil began a lot earlier than that
since little is known about Snow White's
mother and father many of us are left to
assume that they passed away when she
was very young
Snow White's father never made an
appearance and Snow White in the Seven
Dwarves but we do know that he was a
fair man who went by the name of the
first King after losing his young wife
the first King spent in many years in
the state of total devastation that is
until he met grimhilde the first king
soon realized that his daughter needed a
mother which prompted him to get hitched
once more while his actions stemmed from
good intentions he unknowingly sent
himself to an early grave
the cause of the first King's death was
never mentioned in the Disney movie but
it was mentioned in the book the
complete story of Walt Disney's Snow
White and the Seven Dwarves in these old
passages it was confirmed that the Evil
Queen did in fact poison her husband
which granted her the life she'd always
dreamed of now how's that for a wicked
family secrets Princess Jasmine and the
controlling Sultan many of us view
Jasmine as one of the most adventurous
and opinionated Disney Princesses of all
time her strong character traits are
hard to miss and easy to love when we
are first introduced to Jasmine it's
pretty obvious that she's unhappy with
her current lifestyle despite the fact
that she eats the best meals where's the
nicest clothes and sleeps in the
comfiest bed there's something missing
in her life
the Sultan might seem like a joyful and
caring father but in the end there are
many crooked things about him first of
all he's never allowed Jasmine to leave
the palace walls or do anything at all
for a matter of fact I'm
even been outside the palace walls or do
anything at all without a doubt we can
say that the Sultan's views on women's
rights are very poor throughout her 16
years of life jasmine has never seen the
world or even made a friend and that's
just sad
Jasmine's mother has hardly ever
mentioned throughout Aladdin but we do
know that she passed away when Jasmine
was just a little girl the soul Tana
used to read Jasmine a story called Raja
the star tiger after losing her mother
Jasmine found a tiny tiger cub and named
him Raja believing that he'd been sent
to her Pia her mother spirit
all in all Jasmine's life was far from
perfect before Aladdin came and showed
her the world the mysterious death of
Lord Tremaine for some strange reason
the vast majority of Disney Princesses
had to grow up without their mother by
their side and while their fathers did
the best that they could
they couldn't protect their daughters
from their horrible tastes and women
much like Snow White Cinderella's mother
passed away when she was very young
this left her father depressed and
lonely which prompted him to marry the
first woman who showed him any interest
despite believing that Lady Tremaine was
a good fit this theory was lair
disproved when Lord Jermaine's suddenly
passed away it was then that Cinderella
saw her stepmothers true colors and they
were so evil that they chilled her to
the core it didn't take long for Lady
Tremaine and her daughters to take over
the castle as though it was theirs in
the first place which has caused us to
believe that Lord jemaine's death was
premeditated unfortunately there's no
way of proving this theory when solely
looking at the 1950s Disney movie
however there are some clues that hint
towards that it remains immortality for
starters she never remarried after Lord
Jermaine's passing which could prove
that all she ever really wanted was a
beautiful home sadly Lady Tremaine
didn't shed a single tear after her
husband's death and instead of
comforting his daughter she immediately
put her to work does this sound like the
actions of an innocent woman we don't
think so for now it looks as though
Cinderella's family secret starts and
ends with her father Lord Germain
princess bells wicked sisters anyone who
has watched Disney's The Beauty and the
Beast knows that Belle is an only child
after doing some digging though it's
come to life at the bookworm actually
had three sisters since the
the Beast is a rendition of the 16th
century story labelled at libet's it's
only normal for some differences to be
present in the plot did you know that
this Disney movie was actually inspired
by real-life events well it was Fringe
author Gabrielle Suzanne the Barbeau
drew inspiration from the late Petrus
Gonzales this man suffered from
hypertrichosis which causes hair to grow
in big patches all over the body
don't never see me as anything this rare
condition gave way to the fairy tale we
all know and love but to say that
Bravo's rendition was viewer friendly
would be fought in this fairytale
Belle's sisters grew jealous of her
happiness and wealthiness and plotted to
have her killed after convincing the
Beast to let her visit her family
Belle left the castle and went home but
instead of being happy for her her
sisters did everything they could to
keep her from going back to the Beast
they did this in order to aggravate him
believing that he would become furious
enough to devour their more fortunate
sister luckily for Belle she returned
before this could happen the real reason
why Rapunzel was given away before
Disney came out with 2010's tingled the
story of Rapunzel was a lot darker than
we'd like to admit since most Disney
movies are inspired by very dark tells
it's only normal for Disney Princesses
to have shocking family secrets
while many of us believe that Rapunzel
was stolen by Mother Gothel for her
magical hair this isn't truly the case
in the Brothers Grimm version Rapunzel's
mother was so obsessed with getting
pregnant that she forced her husband to
steal magical flowers and roots from an
old witch's garden unable to turn her
down her husband sneaks into the witch's
garden and starts stealing from it
instead of calling him out the witch
watches and allows him to take what he
needs but not before striking a deal
with him in the end
Rapunzel's father agrees to give the
witch his firstborn child on the
accounts that he can take herbs from her
garden at will throughout his wife's
future pregnancies
so basically Rapunzel's father was so
afraid of his wife's pregnancy cravings
that he agreed to give his firstborn
child to a wicked witch as a result
Rapunzel was locked up in a tower for
nearly two decades before being
abandoned by the witch if you're
anything like us you much prefer the
Disney version
princess Aurora's family allowed her to
marry her assailant
okay so the dark truth surrounding
Aurora's family are probably the second
hardest to deal with if you want to find
out which Disney Princesses family has
the most secrets though you'll have to
watch until the end as many of you know
Princess Aurora was sentenced to a
lifetime of sleep on her 16th birthday
while the Disney adaptations sugarcoats
this sentence we're not going to do that
today after pricking her finger with the
spindles flax Princess Aurora lays down
on her bed and falls into a perpetual
slumber in Disney's Sleeping Beauty
Aurora awaits true love's kiss in order
to reawaken her kingdom unfortunately
this isn't technically how things go
down in dumb Batista's busty lays tail
Princess Aurora doesn't wake up until
after she gives birth to twins one of
her newborn twins ends up sucking the
flax out of her finger and breaks the
wicked spell while Aurora was asleep she
was impregnated by a travelling king who
she later ends up marrying if there's
one thing we just can't get over its how
Aurora's family allowed her to marry her
assailant Queen Eleanor his relationship
with Princess Merida it's only normal
for mothers to want the best for their
children in the end though some parents
have to learn that they have little say
over their child's personality and
interests it isn't hard to see that
Queen Eleanor is sometimes disappointed
with Merida's way of life as a matter of
fact this is a concern that she often
voices out loud in Queen Eleanor's mind
her daughter will never find a husband
while acting and dressing the way that
she does well it's time to face the
music
Eleanor because your daughter wants
nothing to do with marriage for the time
being
despite the way that Queen Eleanor acts
throughout the film she eventually
learns to accept her daughter for who
she is
in the end Queen Eleanor's spent her
entire life trying to fit into the mold
of a perfect princess only to find out
that there is no such thing for her sake
she should start paying more mind to
harris Hubert's
and Hamish has they are the ones who are
going to cause the most trouble Ariel is
her father's favorite daughter anyone
living with siblings knows that there's
no such thing as picking favorites
unfortunately for Ariel sisters this
doesn't seem to be the case when it
comes to King Triton Princess Ariel is
the youngest out of seven sisters
coincidentally she's also the most
adventurous while her sisters are
content with singing and dancing for
their father's concerts Arielle wishes
to be somewhere else entirely while she
might cause her father a great deal of
stress she also happens to be his
favorite don't believe us then go ahead
and rewatch the Little Mermaid and see
for yourself
Ariel sisters are often left waiting for
her to show up which obviously bothers
them this makes us wonder if Ariel's
sisters were jealous and annoyed of her
from the get-go should this be the case
it's probably a good thing that Ariel
decided to move onto dry land after all
jealousy can make people do crazy things
the truth behind Pocahontas is father
like many Disney movies Pocahontas was
depicted from real-life events the young
princess is said to have been her
father's favorite daughter
she has her mother's spirit she goes
wherever the wind takes her father who
was the chief of the patent people
originally named her Mitaka however he
gave her the nickname Pocahontas after
getting acquainted with her fierce and
spunky personality despite being a fair
and well-liked chief her father clashed
with English colonizers and was forced
to protect his own people in the Disney
movie Pocahontas stops her father from
executing her lover John Smith but in
real life Pocahontas was never his lover
at all despite all of this there is one
dark truth about Disney's Chief Powhatan
and it's that he wasn't one to show his
enemies mercies while we're led to
believe that Pocahontas was an only
child nurtured by a loving father this
is far from the truth instead she was
simply her father's favorite offspring
else's father dabbled in curious
activities we all know who else Anana
are well we don't know though is who
their parents used to be despite the
fact that King a ganar was a great
father there are some things about him
that just don't make any sense
fans were slightly thrown off over how
many triangular shapes and Illuminati
references there were in frozen
all-in-all it would appear as though
King Agner dabbled in Freemasonry the
arendelle family's coronation scene also
hinted towards these practices but
whether or not dizzy did this on purpose
remains to be confirmed if there's one
thing we can say though it's that frozen
is riddled with dark secrets for
starters King
Inara made some sort of deal with the
trolls to prevent Anna from dying
shortly after both he and his wife
disappeared off the face of the earth
hopefully we'll get to learn more about
this deal once frozen two hits the big
screen in 2019
so which dark family secrets stood out
to you the most let us know in the
comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]